the new england patriots have a new
quarterback mack jones from alabama
slides down the board some thought he
could be taken third by the san
francisco 49ers he wasn't somebody could
be taken eight by the carolina panthers
he wasn't he's there for bill belichick
who didn't have to move and mack jones
with that strong nick saban connection
they talk all the time belichick not
bashful about getting intel from saving
about his guys he heard enough to love
mac jones is the 15th overall pick so
cam newton is the guy for now
we'll see when mac jones gets worked
into the fray this cuts against what
we've seen from the patriots so far in
the offseason it's been about making
moves to win now they didn't have to
move up mac jones fell to them but they
invested the pick in their future a guy
who's drawn some comparisons to tom
brady now takes the spot eventually that
tom brady held for so long it'll be
fascinating to see how it plays out for
mack jones with the new england patriots
and when he'll end up on the field
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports